Alright! So I'll call it my festival dashboard. And then Save. Or Save and Run?
>> Save and Run. Yeah! You can totally see how once we had a bunch of
these it would be really awesome to see
all the information about our festival at a glance.
>> Yeah, sure. So we want to go back to Reports and Modify.
>> Yes.
>> 'Kay. This one? Total revenue?
>> Yep.
>> Since that's the data source for the dashboard.
>> Exactly. And so we want to click Customize
again to modify this report. And so at the
top where it says to Add Filters click Add.
>> okay. So festival, oh, new to, and
even new I want to filter on a festival.
>> So, you want to add, if you click the little arrow next to that. Yep.
>> Festival name?
>> Festival name. And then Cloudstock. Mm-hm.
>> And that's not going to change this becasue all
of are attendees are already there, like that but.
>> Right! But if you would have associated
anyone to Ruffle Blueser.
>> Mm-hm.
>> This would eliminate that.